.
>> Jesse: HEY, BRET.
THANK YOU.
♪
>> Jesse: FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE ARE EXPECTING THE STATE OF
NEVADA TO DUMP SOME BALLOT
RESULTS ANY MINUTE THIS HOUR.
WE ARE SEEING A HEATED SENATE
RACE PLAY OUT THERE WHERE
REPUBLICAN ADAM LAXALT IS UP
ABOUT 15,000 VOTES BUT IT'S NOT
A DECLARED WIN JUST YET BECAUSE
CLARK COUNTY, MEANING LAS VEGAS,
STILL HAS OVER 50,000 MORE VOTES
TO COUNT.
LAXALT'S MARGINS COULD SLIM DOWN
HERE.
WHENEVER CLARK COUNTY DECIDE
IT'S TIME TO COUNT THEIR VOTES.
>> WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT,
THERE'S NO WAY THAT WE CAN MOVE
ANY FASTER THAN WE ARE CURRENTLY
MOVING.
THERE ARE 50,000 BALLOTS.
JUST OVER 50,000 BALLOTS THAT
STILL NEED TO BE TALLIED.
AND OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
THREE DAYS WE WILL GET THEM INTO
THE SYSTEM.
>> Jesse: IF WE ARE LUCKY WE
WILL KNOW THE RESULTS IN ANOTHER
THREE DAYS.
NED CAN'T EVEN FIGURE OUT HOW TO
WORK THEIR CAMERAS AT SOME OF
THESE POLLING LOCATIONS.
THEY ALL WENT DARK IN WASHOE
COUNTY LAST NIGHT.
NO BIG DEAL.
I'M SURE NOTHING ILLEGAL
HAPPENED WHEN THE LIGHTS WERE
OUT AND THE CAMERAS WERE OFF.
OVER IN ARIZONA, BLAKE MASTERS
HAS BEEN MAKING SOME GAINS IN
THE SENATE RACE AGAINST MARK
KELLY BUT HE IS STILL DOWN ABOUT
FIVE.
THE GOVERNOR'S RACE ON THE OTHER
HAND IS A DEAD HEAT.
REPUBLICAN KARI LAKE IS PRETTY
MUCH NECK AND NECK WITH HOBBES.
AND WE THINK THE REMAINING VOTES
COULD GIVE HER A BOOST.
BUT, WHEN ARE THOSE VOTES COMING
IN?
WELL, MARICOPA COUNTY HAS ABOUT
400,000 VOTES LEFT TO COUNT,
CAN'T FIGURE IT OUT.
>> WHEN DO YOU ANTICIPATE THE
VOTES WILL BE COUNTED IN TOTAL,
THOSE 400,000-PLUS VOTES.
>> WELL, WE HAVE -- WE WILL BE
GOING IN TO NEXT WEEK.
THERE IS SOME ONESIE TWOS
ARIZONA LAW.
SEE THE LION SHARE WRAP UP BY
EARLY NEXT WEEK.
>> EARLY NEXT WEEK?
CAN YOU GIVE ME A DAY TALKING
MONDAY?
>> MAYBE, AS LONG AS YOU WON'T
HOLD ME TO IT.
>> Jesse: WE DON'T WANT TO HOLD
YOU TO IT ONESIES TWOSIESES
MAYBE GET RESULTS BY SUNDAY.
FLORIDA WITH THREE TIMES THE
POPULATION GOT RESULTS OUT
ELECTION NIGHT.
WHAT'S IS TAKING ARIZONA AND
NEVADA SO LONG?
ARIZONA DOESN'T EVEN START
COUNTING EARLY VOTES UNTIL
ELECTION DAY.
THEY WANT THE DRAMA.
THEY WANT DELAYED RESULTS.
THEY DESIGNED IT THIS WAY.
THEY START WITH MAIL-IN BALLOTS,
THEN THEY COUNT DAY OF BALLOTS,
AND THEN THEY FINALLY GET AROUND
TO DROP OFF BALLOTS.
HEAVEN FORBID YOU COUNT
EVERYTHING AT THE SAME TIME.
THAT WOULD MAKE TOO MUCH SENSE.
AND ARE THEY EVEN COUNTING
AROUND THE CLOCK?
OF COURSE NOT.
POLL WORKERS ONLY WORK FROM 9:00
TO 5:00.
WHAT'S THE HURRY ANYWAY?
IT'S JUST AN ELECTION.
AND WHEN THE POLL WORKERS ARE
COUNTING, THEY ARE OPENING UP
ENVELOPES ONE BY ONE AND
CHALLENGING SIGNATURES THAT
DON'T MATCH.
>> IN ARIZONA, THE LAW ALSO
ALLOWS VOTERS TO CURE A
SIGNATURE, SO, BECAUSE WE CAN OR
WE HAVE TRAINED STAFF WHO LOOK
AT EVERY SINGLE SIGNATURE THAT
THAT VOTER MIGHT HAVE ON FILE TO
FIND THAT COMPARISON, IF WE
AREN'T ABLE TO FIND THAT
COMPARISON SIGNATURE, WE DO
REACH OUT TO THE VOTER.
WE CALL THEM, WE TEXT THEM, WE
EMAIL THEM IF WE HAVE THAT
INFORMATION ON FILE AND WE SEND
THEM A LETTER.
VOTERS HAVE BY LAW UNTIL
WEDNESDAY AT 5:00 P.M. TO CURE
THAT SIGNATURE.
>> Jesse: HEY, MICHAEL, THIS IS
PAUL OVER AT MARICOPA COUNTY
POLLING STATION, CAN YOU GIVE US
A CALL BACK?
IT'S ABOUT YOUR SIGNATURE ON
YOUR BALLOT.
ANN MARIE, WE WILL HAVE TO SEND
PAUL OUT A LETTER.
THEY ARE JUST SITTING AROUND FOR
PEOPLE TO MAIL IN A NEW
SIGNATURE?
ARIZONA IS LIKE THE GIRL THAT
EVERYBODY IS READY TO GO OUT TO
DINNER AND SHE HASN'T EVEN
SHOWERED YET.
TAKE YOUR TIME, HONEY.
THE RESERVATION WAS AT 7:30 BUT
YOU KNOW WHETHER A?
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WE WILL GO HUNGRY.
IN NEVADA, IT'S JUST A FREE FOR
ALL COME ELECTION DAY.
THEY HAVE NO STRUCTURE.
JUST LIKE ARIZONA.
THEY START COUNTING ALL VOTES ON
ELECTION DAY.
EVEN ONES SITTING IN PILES FOR
WEEKS.
BUT IN NEVADA, THEY MIX THEM ALL
TOGETHER IN A PILE.
THE MAIL-IN BALLOTS ARE MIXED IN
WITH THE DAYS OF VOTES AND MIXED
IN WITH THE DROPPED OFF BALLOT
AND OH YEAH THEY GIVE VOTERS
ANOTHER WEEK TO FIX THEIR
SIGNATURES, TOO.
SO WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
ELECTIONS USED TO BE DECIDED ON
ELECTION NIGHT.
"AMERICAN IDOL" CAN HANDLE
MILLIONS OF VOTES IN A
COMMERCIAL BREAK BUT IT TAKES
ARIZONA, NEVADA A WEEK?
NONE OF IT MAKES SENSE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT THE SYSTEM TO
MAKE SENSE.
THE LONGER SOME OF THESE RACES
DRAG OUT FOR, THE BETTER IT IS
FOR DEMOCRATS.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE CREATED A
SYSTEM CENTERED AROUND BALLOTS
NOT VOTES.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WINNING YOUR VOTE
ANYMORE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT PERSUADING YOU.
IT'S ABOUT FLOODING THE STATE
WITH AS MANY BALLOTS AS POSSIBLE
AND GETTING THEM FILLED OUT
DEMOCRAT.
AND YOU'LL NEVER GUESS WHO IS
INVOLVED IN THE BALLOT GAME.
THE SECOND GENTLEMAN, KAMALA'S
MAIN SQUEEZE.
>> KAMALA AND DOUG -- BY THE
WAY, DOUG CRISSCROSSED THE
COUNTRY.
I THINK HE DID -- HE SPENT MORE
TIME MAKING SURE THAT THE FOLKS
WHO ACTUALLY COUNT THE VOTES IN
THESE STATES DO IT HONESTLY.
AND THANK YOU, PAL.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Jesse: DOUG EMHOFF IS IN
CHARGE OF ELECTION SECURITY?
IS THIS A JOKE?
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S HUSBAND AND
ENTERTAINMENT LAWYER IS
CRISSCROSSING THE COUNTRY UNDER
THE RADAR MAKING SURE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE COUNT THE VOTES?
JOE BIDEN'S PAL?
IT'S EASIER TO HAVE A BALLOT
STRATEGY THAN IT IS TO HAVE AN
INFLATION STRATEGY, I GUESS.
AND IT WORKS.
WANT TO KNOW WHY SOMEONE LIKE
JOHN FETTERMAN WAS ABLE TO WIN?
OVER A MILLION PEOPLE IN
PENNSYLVANIA VOTED EARLY.
YOU GET 50 DAYS BEFORE AN
ELECTION TO GET YOUR BALLOT IN.
50 DAYS.
SO DEMOCRATS HAVE A MONTH AND A
HALF HEAD START TO WORK THEIR
BALLOTS.
OVER 20% OF ALL BALLOTS IN
PENNSYLVANIA CAME IN BEFORE
ELECTION DAY.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE WORKING THEIR
TAILS OFF FOR THOSE 50 DAYS.
WERE THE REPUBLICANS?
I DON'T KNOW.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT.
FETTERMAN HID HIS CONDITION FOR
MONTHS.
DEBATED A WEEK BEFORE THE
ELECTION, SHOWED HE COULDN'T
TALK BUT BY THEN IT DIDN'T
MATTER.
FETTERMAN HAD BANKED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF VOTES ALREADY.
DEMOCRATS WHO VOTED EARLIER FOR
FETTERMAN AND SAW THAT DEBATE
SORRY, IT'S TOO LATE.
IN ARIZONA, WE'RE SEEING THE
SAME THING PLAY OUT.
KATIE HOBBS DIDN'T EVEN DEBATE
KARI LAKE.
SHE DIDN'T THINK SHE HAD TO.
SHE WAS SECRETARY OF STATE AND
SHE KNEW THE GAME BETTER THAN
ANYONE.
ARIZONA HAD ABOUT A MILLION AND
A HALF EARLY BALLOTS COME IN.
DO YOU THINK IT WAS BECAUSE
PEOPLE COULDN'T WAIT TO VOTE FOR
KATIE HOBBS?
PROBABLY THE LAMEST CANDIDATE OF
THIS ELECTION?
NO.
THEY JUST FLOODED ARIZONA WITH
BALLOTS.
KATIE IS THE SECRETARY OF STATE
IS IN CHARGE OF RUNNING THE
ELECTIONS WHERE, YOU KNOW, THERE
HAPPENED TO BE AN INK SHORTAGE
THAT BLEW OUT 20% OF POLLING
MACHINES IN MARICOPA COUNTY ON
ELECTION DAY.
HOW DOES A CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR GET TO BE IN CHARGE OF
RUNNING THE ELECTION FOR
GOVERNOR?
WELL, BECAUSE SHE REFUSED TO
STEP DOWN AND THE LIBERAL MEDIA
DIDN'T PUT ANY PRESSURE ON HER.
THE ONLY REASON THIS RACE IS
TIGHT IS BECAUSE KARI LAKE IS A
GREAT CANDIDATE.
BUT WE DIDN'T SEE THAT PLAY OUT
IN SOME OF THESE OTHER RACES
WHERE, YOU KNOW, WE WILL BE
HONEST REPUBLICANS DIDN'T PUT
OUT THE BEST CANDIDATES.
AND FLORIDA GOT ITS RED WAVE
BECAUSE DESANTIS HAD A GREAT
RECORD AND A GREAT CAMPAIGN AND
WE FOUND OUT HE WON THAT NIGHT
BECAUSE THEY COUNT EARLY AND
AROUND THE CLOCK AND KNOCKED OUT
THE SHENANIGANS.
HOW DO THEY PUMP THESE BALLOTS
OUT THERE?
WELL, PEOPLE HAVE TO REQUEST
THEM OR THEY DON'T.
OUR PRODUCER AT "PRIMETIME" SAYS
HE GOT SIX BALLOTS SENT TO HIS
OLD ADDRESS AND HE DIDN'T
REQUEST A THING.
HE DOESN'T EVEN LIVE IN THE SAME
STATE ANYMORE.
AND OUR OTHER PRODUCER HAS A
GRANDMOTHER WHO WOULD BE 116
YEARS OLD.
SHE HAS BEEN DEAD FOR A WHILE,
BUT SHE HAS BEEN GETTING BALLOTS
FOR THE LAST FEW ELECTION
CYCLES.
YOU CAN ALSO REQUEST BALLOTS
ONLINE.
CAN YOU REQUEST BALLOTS FOR
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS ONLINE?
WHO IS CHECKING?
SO WHAT DO REPUBLICANS DO?
THEY CAN'T RELY ON ELECTION DAY
VOTING ANYMORE.
YOU GOT TO DO SOMETHING EARLIER.
THEY HAVE TO GET IN ON THE EARLY
VOTING GAME.
I MEAN, THE EARLY BALL